- So, what do we do now?
Do we need to report it?
He's been accused
and we know about it.
- It's not a credible accusation.
- Although it worked perfectly
as a novel,
when you adapt it into a series,
it changes.
We created a show that has
a very strong aesthetic.
We exposed for the outside world,
and made the people silhouettey and dark.
Stuck in their own prison.
- Since we have Morten directing
all eight episodes,
it really has a uniformity
of directorial vision.
And it feels
incredibly cinematic.
Same for our costume designer,
whose challenge is
how do I make them feel
as realistic as possible?
- They're saying
he looks smug and remorseless.
He's not even 15 years old.
- It's a murder mystery
that is all about the characters,
how they experience it.
- One of our challenges was how
do I not create a parody of these people?
How do I really do justice to them?
- How could this even happen?
I can't get my head around it.
- I don't know how many times
we've been sitting behind the monitor,
and we thought,
"We actually got the perfect Andy."
Chris brings both a strength
and a vulnerability to the character,
which is really hard.
- I knew my son.
- That's it?
That's your justification?
- I was being a father.
- And Michelle is just so open
and very honest.
And between Jaeden
and the other actors, everyone,
they're so fantastic.
- Remember that in their eyes,
it isn't just Jacob who's guilty.
You all are.
- These actors have that ability,
not just to embody
the complexity of these characters,
but to project out from the screen
and to connect with the viewer.
- It's sort of like
doing a play.
It's, you know, you have these kind of
big, long, two-hander scenes
which are written so brilliantly.
- If you think about the complexity
of scripting eight hours,
you're building a Swiss watch.
- Start from the beginning.
- It was a really cohesive team,
and it all came from this place
that we're just in love
with this story and these characters.
- And that's very exciting to me,
to see this world
really developed in a vivid
and full and complete way.
- It's a character-driven,
intense thriller.
All these twists and turns, you just
hold on to it and go on this ride.
- You're ruining his life.
You're gonna destroy it.
- There is more going on here
than you're aware of.
- More than what?
Tell me, goddamn it!